[Music]
yeah these folks are kind of stripped
of patience on the las vegas strip the
repaving one of the most famous streets
in the world announced last year
as a five-year-long project broken up
into shorter pieces parts but
viewers becky and joe they're not happy
about it becky writes i don't understand
why las vegas boulevard or any street in
las vegas remains torn up with
construction
stop dawdling around and get it done and
from joe
when if ever are they going to finish
the road construction on las vegas
boulevard from downtown to spring
mountain
well becky and joe you're not alone i do
have a partial update but first
a quick lesson on who's in charge where
las vegas boulevard north of sahara
that's in the city of las vegas
south of sahara the strip is controlled
by clark county so the only update i
have for now is from the county where
spokesman dan kulin tells me
about the stretch from sahara down to
spring mountain lane closures
lane shifts will continue until that
section is done
which should be in july still need to
check with the city of las vegas on the
work from sahara north to downtown but
thanks for writing in
please buckle up drive carefully and put
down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com